dix-huit mille quatre cents kilomètres
de paris au sud de la nouvelle zélande
jamais fait cyclotourisme gib.a bras
tout j'ai en moi donc j'ai acheté ce
vélo donc ici je me suis déplacé en vélo
j'ai fait
750 km en vélo c'est devenu une part du
voyage c'est pas juste un moyen de
déplacement
isabelle a abandonné le stop pour un
vélo pour aller de ferme en ferme ici on
dit les stations elle a décidé
d'utiliser la bicyclette une bicyclette
qu'il aura à mener au bout du monde on
est à l'extrémité sud de la
nouvelle-zélande il ya quelques îlots
après après un plus que l'antarctique
c'est aussi au strike aux employeurs
lingerie cela c'est vraiment le bout du
monde là c'est plus symbolique qu'autre
chose mais ça fait plaisir et je
pourrais pas être plus long et l'année
dernière j'y croyais pas l année
dernière je me disais il faut que je
trouve un boulot même si ça ne plaît pas
tant pis mais vous diront sans bobos et
puis si ça peut être un cdi dans une
boîte de merde à ton mieux parce qu on
emploi fixe et puis je pourrais avoir
mon appartement ma petite voiture mais
c'est tout l'inversé de mon caractère et
je sais qu'il ya plein de gens qui sont
comme ça qu'ils se sentent obligés
d'avoir une vie qui n'ont pas désiré
parce que parce que ça se fait pas de
clôturer ses études par un voyage parce
que c'est une perte de temps mais non
c'est aberrant
je me rends compte que finalement le
style de vie que j'avais jusqu'à
maintenant le fait de vivre dans une
ville c'est pas l'unique solution être
autre chose que j'ai besoin d'apprendre
de découvrir
j'avais envie de vivre ces moments là
c'était en moi
grubb small piece of bread which he
can't make sandwich à financer ce vase
grâce à des bourses
donc comme j'habitais à paris j'ai pu
avoir labouré aventure d'american eagle
européenne sur est donc la suivante en
mille front et ensuite grâce à ça je
puis obtenir notre beau s'appelle de
fichman la vision de 5000 francs dont 45
mille francs au total
ça suffit puisque quand je suis dans des
stations fellows et nourrit donc ce qui
nous coûte cher c'est la bouffe entre
deux sous les déplacements et frais
annexes
et puis évidemment le billet d'avion ne
s'agit plus avant un tarif intéressant
c'est sûr elle remonte vers le nord où
elle a trouvé un job dans une grosse
ferme d'élevage de moutons mais elle a
du temps devant elle
le temps de chercher autre chose comme
j'ai quelques jours de battement
je me renseigne pour savoir si a peint
des gens qui travaillent à cheval en
coin jury demande et on se remet d'une
11e place
son voyage elle y as pensé pendant deux
ans mais lorsqu'elle a posé les pieds
sur la nouvelle zélande
elle n'avait qu'un seul contact arrivé
ici je suis allé voir l'association de
fermiers à christchurch
ils m'ont donné quelques adresses
quelques numéros de téléphone et puis
après ces démarches ça se fait beaucoup
par téléphone parce que ce n'est pas
toujours évident d'arriver comme ça chez
les gens je téléphone je leur explique
que je sais monter à cheval et que
j'aimerais bien travailler chez eux soit
avoir choisi le rendez vous à nos
cobayes station la firme noko my où elle
est attendue dans un endroit
premier jour les cobayes ne parle pas
isabelle boudineau du bout des lèvres et
puis attendent de voir ce que je vaux à
chf à l'extérieur c'est pas payé je suis
logé nourri partir du moment où je suis
pas vraiment professionnel je suis pas
pro by professionnel sont ratés
difficile de demander plus
le travail ici redescendre les moutons
de la montagne avant l'hiver l'essentiel
c'est d'avoir des chiens tout se fait
avec les chiens les dons qu'ils ont tous
au minimum six chiens et c'est leur seul
trésor d'ailleurs il ya des cobayes qui
n'ont rien ils n'ont pas de voiture on
pas les maisons ils ont rien mais ils
ont leurs six chiens et lé chemin qui va
le vendre 100 mille francs français
c'est énorme dans les connu pour quatre
jours le premier jour on va rejoindre
une hutte et puis après on va rassembler
les moutures martyrs de la star du rap
en base
en trois journées donc ils doivent
rassembler 15 mille moutons éparpillés
dans les collines message en fait depuis
que je suis toute petite
c'est comme beaucoup de passion ça
s'explique par un jour j'ai lu il
fallait les duels alors que personne
physique sur elle ça va arriver parental
pendant cinq six mois et ça m'est et
surtout jamais envie de monter à cheval
les heures défilent ça c'est que j'avais
même pas quand je pouvais supporter
d'attenté 16 heures d'affilée et de
continuer à galoper à huit heures du
soir alors qu'on l'a cédé à 90 m et
l'impression de liberté quand on est à
cheval comme ça qu'on part ça fait cinq
ans qu'on est sur le cheval on commence
à ce que je fais là avec des hommes que
je connais pas qu'est ce que je fais au
mieux de riom l'hiver n'est pas loin
dans la vallée la pluie et glacé
quelques centaines de mètres plus haut
sur les montagnes elle tombe sous forme
de neige
ce que l'on appelle une hutte ici cette
baraque en tôle
c'est bien mais il est vraiment froid
les pieds je lai toute la journée la
pluie sur la tête
mais bon ceci dit c'est beau je suis
regardé en face il commence à neiger sur
le haut des montagnes et puis je le
savais où je le savais c'est pas la
peine de me plaindre
j'en sais rien parce que jamais arrivé
mais pour le libre il a l'air très bien
tout seuls nos adorables en cobol ça me
dérange pas et savent que je suis pas
venu ici pour trouver un mari ni un
copain donc ils vont boire un vin doux
nom c'est une atmosphère que j'aime bien
surtout après des journées de travail
comme ça une bonne ambiance
[Musique]
c'est un monde dormant de macho et c'est
un peu le pas mais c'est aussi beaucoup
aux jeux parce qu'en fait dans leur
approche des paysages vus dans la revue
la contemplation dans leur vie
quotidienne ils sont extrêmement féminin
ils ont deux sensibilités totalement
féminine
[Musique]
m
jakarta en quelques jours marié parvenu
à se faire des connaissances un
journaliste local a accepté de l'aider
l'annoncé de la prochaine libération de
prisonniers politiques lui a donné
l'idée de tenter d'en rencontrer dans la
prison elle espère le scoop dans la
première enceinte de la prison il ya
déjà pas mal de reporter et les familles
des emprisonnés
[Musique]
réduit le dit 'core' donc
j'ai une hausse qu'il est
wang min a toutefois ce possible to go
inside man 2 just a deux bras dj just go
inside out of two cities même une partie
de format ebook writing bockel j'avais
une pâte en famille et it's you can't
take me
[Musique]
skins donné son ok maintenant je sais
que j'ai passé mon objectif c'est chez
pias j'aime me laisser les fans et ouais
je sais les faire rire des tombes de les
amadouer et ça peut marcher
[Applaudissements]
rihanna se posent aux visiteurs liu liu
hockey non mais tu as seen deux chiffres
à nice and that is pas si mauvais
chiffrs us to me ou de deux chiffres non
non non de bien belles images dans le
stand stand sont les causes de chiffres
ça y est ayo de chief le deux miles
bon je sais pas comment je m'en sortir
je suis aller calmer comme ça un petit
peu puis je vais y aller
en fait elle ne pourra pas y aller une
seule photo
la quête est maigre la rumeur annonce
qu'un groupe d'islamistes proches du
pouvoir se dirige vers le parlement pour
déloger les étudiants qu'ils l'occupent
militaire ok ok il ya tous les
militaires ont fait qu'ils arrivent par
là bas et ses chansons l'inquiétude des
spahis l'ont tous regardent attentes se
dresse devant moi je me demande aussi ce
que voir les militaires des boulets
comme ça avec leurs mitraillettes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'un côté les étudiants qui veulent que
tous les proches de suharto l'ancien
dictateur quitte le pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
aa
de l'autre côté les islamistes qui
veulent que les étudiants eux quittent
les lieux
[Applaudissements]
m
un mélange de peur de plaisir et c'est
assez particulier c'est la première fois
que je veux c'est loupé
que je fais quand même très data si on
attaque ensemble quelque peu plus bouger
alors ça commence
[Applaudissements]
je me prend je m'en prenais truc dans la
figure
makino un truc
[Applaudissements]
j'aime pas du tout j'avais souvent
coupés mais quelle excitation
[Applaudissements]
le pérou cusco au xvème siècle avant
l'arrivée des espagnols c'étaient la
capitale de l'empiré inca enquête choix
la langue des indiens coup ce qu'on veut
dire le nombril du monde
aujourd'hui le nombril du monde est
envahi de touristes mais il suffit de
quelques centaines de pas pour ne plus
en voir un et se retrouvait dans un
marché typique
alors on peut faire des rencontres
étranges
geagea manifs et des cérémonies oui à sa
sortie ok notre dame à sarlat c'est ok
ben amor
[Musique]
hélas
départ ou non de couverture mais ça peut
aussi être autrement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
ce
personne ne connaît la totalité des
effets de la potion magique des sorciers
de cusco apparemment cependant elle
provoque une sorte d'hilarité la fin du
rituel la plante sacrée des andes
la feuille de coca est un signe de croix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une victoire la libye rituel physique à
ceux qui savent qu'on est à florac aucun
c'était peu après on va voir la
pachamama pour souvient que cavaignac à
cuzco pérou par été une totale à coût
égal à mort merrick site dans le but
d'assurer négative la musique
c'est impressionnant qu'est ce qui vous
a impressionné
ça surprend je passe des heures savais
pas que ça pouvait exister quoi on a au
courant des histoires de ça nous est
tous en inde
ici - quoi et puis moi je passe tel un
gamin christianisme 5 à quoi ça c'est
bizarre grosse réserve de bonnes
énergies pour marco et philippe qui leur
aura coûté 30 francs mais tout le monde
n'a pas leur chance tout le monde ne
rencontre pas les bons sorcier
c'est en france il ya le salon
migration qui est venu dans
l'hôtel je suis hébergé et apparemment
il était en train de chercher de la
drogue et comme ils ont rien trouvé
j'ai pas si c'est la rage ou ou
l'impuissance mais ils ont décidé de
m'embarquer en disant que j'étais une
touriste illégal
je leur ai montré mon passeport mon
passeport il est parfaitement légal et
je sais je sais pas je sais je sais même
pas le motif pour lequel ils m'ont
embarqué soit disant ils voulaient
vérifier
si j'avais de l'argent si j'avais
suffisamment d'argent pour rester au
paiement et caetera et
et en fait cet argent on voulait il
voulait se soutirer pour eux quoi c'est
quoi c'est les doigts ces défis sont
l'immigration
comment s'habiller comme alain billon
civile dit mais toi la petite française
mione jolie et tout pourquoi tu veux tu
reste pas avec un nous et tout
un conseil vient tout seul pour
récupérer le passeport simon longtemps
ferme
ça a été ça a été horrible c'était 10
torture psychologique bien sûr j'ai eu
peur ils voulaient m'enfermer il voulait
m'inventer à un chef d'inculpation et
ils ont tous les droits et dans ce pays
de toute façon si on n'a pas les billets
le flic fait ce qu'il veut c'est la foi
ni quoi je pense que je le tiens on
n'entend parler que je ne sais pas c'est
pas comment faire que jeu
j'ai un petit peu perdues jeu la
française perdue au perche où es tu vois
les cp six mois en fait j'étais venu à
lima pour travailler dans une garderie
pour enfants dénutris dans un bidonville
un humanitaire mais
au niveau de l'argent
harvey pu j'avais plus
[Musique]
j'ai voulu appeler mois l'ambassade ont
refusé ils m'ont pas laissé après ouais
ça fait ne m'ont pas laissé appeler ni
ni
ni un appel téléphonique c'est une
chance que je les ai rencontrés parce
que j'ai besoin de parler à des français
d'avoir des conseils aussi je ne sais
plus comment faire
[Musique]
en fait la petite française perdue s'en
sortira avec l'aide d'un avocat
il lui en aura coûté 180 francs les
avocats de cusco savent faire il faut
dire qu'ils ont la pratique
les autorités ont semble-t-il décidé de
mettre un terme à une fréquentation
touristique qui ne rapporte pas beaucoup
les touristes sac à dos et sans le sou
ne sont plus les bienvenus
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
je sais ça je choisir et sa maman
un colloque
[Applaudissements]
c'est une manifestation révolutionnaire
comme historiquement c'est assez c'est
assez chargé en terrorisme en révolution
comme la bolivie che guevara qui était
en bolivie très actif
ici ils sont si lumineux le chef s'est
bêtement fait avoir je crois pour une
histoire de clopes drôle de
révolutionnaire ses compagnes héros sont
des paysans qui continuent la lutte pour
obtenir le droit de récolter la coca
[Musique]
et
les terres de nos cobayes l'hiver avance
il est grand temps de retrouver les
moutons
[Musique]
les moments où c'est en train de faire
quelque chose je suis à cheval c'est mou
ça n'avance pas et puis il ya une espèce
de joie qui montrent que je peux pas
expliquer je me mets à regarder les
paysages à contempler et sebo quoi
j'apprécie ce que je vis les paysages
c'est important pour moi les gens c'est
essentiel mais c'est aussi important de
vivre dans un environnement bourg c'est
pas anodin retourner dans un endroit les
ça finit par vous envahir et vous
grignotez fini par trouver tout gris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une journée un peu particulière
parce qu'il faut rassembler les moutons
qui sont là et là ça fait 38 ha problème
c'est que c'est très très dur de repérer
les moutons parce que il ya de la neige
à l'est ce qu'on appelle le tu as accès
espèce de torpeur qui de loin sont vos
moutons il ya des rochers garçons moment
donc c'est extrêmement difficile de les
repérer ouais ouais là je suis bien je
me sens vraiment mis aux voix
quinze mille moutons qui même de l'autre
côté de la terre ont des comportements
de moutons il faut que l'un se décide à
passer pour que les quatorze 1999 autres
prennent la décision de le suivre
c'était un peu dur puisqu'il ya quand
même à 13 heures 14 heures d'affilée et
j'ai vraiment très très froidement ça me
plaît assez pauvre
non
[Applaudissements]
la gare de cusco à 8 heures le matin
pour un voyage de 13 heures vers le sud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
13h pour guère plus de 200 kilomètres
jusqu à puno au bord du lac titicaca
[Musique]
les trains péruvien comporte trois
classes les voyageurs des wagons
économique des bourses 50 francs pour
les 200 km ils ont rarement l'occasion
de s'asseoir à côté de touristes 50
francs plus une piécette pour le groupe
de musiciens que l'on rencontre presque
à chaque voyage dans les trains des
andes
[Musique]
après
et au plateau un bon bol d'air marc et
philippe s'y sentent plus à l'aise qu'en
ville quand on a une citadelle en
montagne il se sent oppressé par les
montagnes quand on va montana où je
pense à marin en ville sans presser par
la ville
la première chose que j'ai envie de
faire quand je suis en vie de ce moment
d'aller quoi je passe en ville je
m'arrête pas
[Musique]
oui ça se paie
c'est qu'on n'en fait plus ouais je
crois
bien que le train de charles
et
pour être dans les wagons de première
classe il faut payer 180 francs pour les
13 heures de quoi changer les faciès des
voyageurs non seulement elle a blanchi
mais on parle de plus en plus les
langues étrangères l'anglais et
l'allemand
jack ma vie tourne autour de la ligne de
chemin de fer pour les villages de
france photo on dirait qu à l'ouest
américain dans les salles possible dans
le salon reste un style qui convoyait
avec des grandes plaines mon site et
n'affecte sa veut ça ici quoi là on en
train d'entrer dans l'image qu'il fait
tout le monde a dû perdre quoi comment
savoir ce qu'en pense qu'on a vu en kart
en photo dans les bouquins avant d'en
cesser les villes de passage maintenant
ça devient
ono sur une rive du lac titicaca à 3800
mètres d'altitude le titicaca 15 fois le
lac léman superficie
pour eux la dernière balade avant la
partie sérieuse de leur voyage là on va
sonner la montagne c'est les deux îles
deux îles de ce type qui à lille de ta
qui l'aident à montagny il a préféré
prendre un nom d'annie parce que déjà
c'est beaucoup moins touristique il ya
moins de monde c'est là qu'on peut
rencontrer plus facilement des gens de
plus c'est une espèce d'organisation à
l'orphelinat
donc c'est pas mal de voir ce à quoi au
bord de ce lac est née l'une des plus
riches civilisations de l'histoire de
l'humanité l'empiré inca
depuis que je suis petit j'ai toujours
rêvé de voir le lac titicaca on regarde
un peu autour depuis là on se dit que
keith halak qui navigue depuis du
paréage millénaire qu'est les gens qui
ont réussi à vivre là depuis des
millénaires et en comprendre pourquoi
ils ont vécu là ce que ce magnifique
c'est ce pur soit authentique n'arrive
pas trop à définir en fait ce qu'on
ressent dose de 2 voire et si enfin live
même pas y croire les incas qui avons
les saccages des conquistadors avaient
construit des palais plus beau que les
nôtres les indiens de l'époque vénérer
le soleil ils pensaient que c'était les
larmes de ce dieu qui avait rempli cette
vallée pour former le lac un dieu soleil
qui ne s'était pas remis de la
disparition de ces enfants tués par le
puma avec eux sur le bateau quelques
touristes et un jeune allemand qui lui
n'est pas un touriste il vient
travailler
c'est encore l'abaisser en france
objecteur pension de conscience
seulement voilà il dit exact we can work
des restes de corps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les habitants de l'île avaient tous été
massacrés par les conquistadors d'autres
indiens sont venus bien plus tard les
remplacer aujourd'hui encore la mort
plane sur un mandat ni ici se trouve un
orphelinat la mort et la vie
[Musique]
non pas les bronzés si cet accueil leur
a été réservé c'est grâce à la présence
du jeune allemand
les orphelins sont venus recevoir celui
qui vient vivre avec eux et travailler
pour eux les habitants des montagnes ont
réussi jusqu'à présent à s'opposer à la
construction d'un hôtel sur leur île il
accepte par contre d'héberger les
voyageurs c'est quoi aussi bas l'abba
indiens ont bien logés chez l'habitant
enfin comme on dit c'est votre choix
[Applaudissements]
un bed and breakfast pour 20 francs tout
compris la nuit et les trois repas
générac étals dans l'île
il n'y a pas de médecins pas de
médicaments pour soigner on a recours à
des tisanes traditionnel truc qui fout
la paix non je dis beaucoup ça pour
l'attitude pas que ça j'suis pas se fait
passer ça soulage pas mal sa confiance à
propos mastiquer les feuilles sa dope un
peu ça ça stimule quoi
et vous ça vous fait des jeux pas trop
ressenti quoi le psycho tout apprendre
plus cette tisane c'est le maté coca
pour convertir ses meilleurs niveaux de
vie résume pas à un auteur si je pars
demain la faille dans une paysage pas et
chaque compte en devises la cua là la
pression sur la côte d'azur dans le sud
de la france plus en provence sans cette
chaleur étouffante écrasante sens et de
ce bruit ce fond sonore ce touriste et
arrêt pur fait très calme et pas 1 m
puis c'est le silence absolu
là on trouve vraiment la peine on a
l'impression d'être sur l'île déserte
dans tout le monde qu'un tout petit
village et tous les gens sont
accueillants en fait en direct sont
restés à l'état originel
on dirait qu'ils n'ont pas changé de
mentalité ils ont pas été pourri par
l'occident
kss kss national perd tout ne soit pas
manger à midi n'ont jamais vu le savoir
après
je vous passe
il serait venu sur amende thani l'an
dernier il n'aurait pas eu d'électricité
il y a quelques mois seulement qu'un
groupe électrogène a été installé sur
l'île deux heures de lumière chaque soir
avec extinction des feux à 20h et la
lumière
8h30 à 18h
au même moment à jakarta le jour se lève
marie a décidé de tenter d'expédier ses
pellicules toutes les photos qu'elle a
prises depuis son arrivée à lagence
parisienne fdb qui a accepté de les
diffuser
elle ne pouvait pas savoir que les
autorités avaient justement choisi cette
fin de nuit pour faire évacuer les
derniers irréductibles du parlement
qu'il continuait d'occuper bonjour je
voudrais parlé à florice de bonneville
s'il vous plaît c'est de la part de
marie benard j'appelle de jakarta merci
je vais aller à l'aéroport je vais
essayer de trouver un passager je vous
rappel après pour vous dire à quel avion
et d'arrivée d'accord d'un côté des
problèmes d'expédition de l'autre des
moyens expéditif
[Applaudissements]
wasquehal et c'est porteur france là
aucune forme de bandes inferis elles
font ce desk président
air france air france desk ici
ok hagen tous deux terminé à notre
gauche touraine de dié pote goto 10 f
comme tout digue au 12e comme tous ceux
des sceaux a need to find et fo a ici
non non i've been there is no other way
i see ya oai chinois sinon terrisse
avant tout goto puce jetée galeriste
c'est qu'être non maîtrisée unit ou cinq
films au quotidien why not
d'ailleurs cette cassette
bon ok demain matin je vais attend que
quelqu'un qui rentre et puis je vais
proposer que speak french oui bonjour
j'ai un service à vous demander je suis
journaliste photographe et je dois
envoyer des photos
à paris est ce que c'est possible que je
vous donne le paquet de photos et vous
l'envoyez fonds et quelqu'un viendra le
chercher à l'arrivée ça vous pose pas de
problème on c'est super non y'a que des
photos c'est pas de la drogue
vous pouvez vérifier il n'y a pas de
problème d'accord allez-y jeu
règles justes on 13 personnes portera
bonheur presse rouleau 468 photo à
quelle heure vous arrivez à paris 6e
6h20 du matin tu d'accord merci une fois
y'a tout dessus il ya numéro de
téléphone j'ai laissé mon numéro ici à
votre mari et fall aucun voile avec
d'accord
merci bon voyage des étudiants ont été
évacués bien avant que les photos
partant quelques heures le calme est
revenu à jakarta les photos sont
dépassés
[Musique]
l'autre côté de l'hémisphère sud la paz
la capitale la plus haute du monde
la bolivie
[Musique]
pour marc et philippe les derniers jours
du voyage à 40 km de la capitale
bolivienne le huayna potosi 6000 et 95 m
leur objectif
depuis quand celle me beau le guide
chamoniard leur a montré la photo le
jour de leur départ
au début on la voit pas après on arrive
sur l alto sur le but l'altiplano là on
commence à la voir on s'approche on
s'approche pour ses interminables
alors la plupart du temps on regarde ce
qui est autour il ya beaucoup de lacs
très plat ainsi mon sens fait peut-être
qui planait et puis on s'approche et sur
la voie et là ça fait un peu peu comme
quand ça on s'approche du massif du
mont-blanc s'approche mère l'appelle
puis house et c'est devant nous comme
une église comme une cathédrale grand
truc ce qu'ils vont descendre sur leur
surf set face à l'ombre actuellement 700
mètres très raide de neige et de glace
bon à l'aventuré qu'elle commence
maintenant on pourra découvrir une
nouvelle montagne je vois c'est
impressionnant quand on time a
l'impression d'un grand glacier tout
c'est bien plus grand que chez nous et
plus d'engagement c'est plus loin par de
risque qu'ils soient la transe pas
pareil je sais pas si tu vas se refait
une belle pente tranquille et tout ça
c'est pas pareil que quand tu sors fait
un truc un peu plus chaud un peu plus au
raid ou tu prends conscience qu'il ya
danger quoi objectif
dans les alpes on arrive à aller au
sommet dans la journée à redescendre la
journée à la personne porter n'est
complètement autonome ici on est tout de
suite un peu loin quoi des fois il faut
une semaine une semaine pour faire un
saut mais aller retour dont fait trois
jours de marche d'approché faut des fois
utilisé un porteur ou pour avoir ruiné
l'extérieur peut pas être autonome comme
dans les alpes nelson quantock hellos
primes hâtif nelson est âgée de 13 ans
pour les 30 kg sur ses épaules et ses
jambes
le chef des porteurs fait payer 6
dollars par jour 36 francs nelson ne nie
pas combien lui touche effectivement
marc et philippe ne confie jamais au
porteur leur surf superstition en tous
les cas c'est leur outil le plus
précieux une demi journée pour arriver
au camp de base 5200 mètres d'altitude
l'avantagé c'est qu'on ne sait quoi
quand on dort sans glace et des six
pompes l'énergie ça ça fatigue ça use
en plus ça bouge donc de l'un qui disent
ça fait sexy chic aussi mais dormir au
sexe et bien c'est mieux
donc demain on part on célèbrera vers 2
heures pour partir vers 3 heures on
mettra quatre heures jusqu'à l'arrivée à
peu près en allant tout doucement la rue
mais c'est la première crevasses en fait
d'un glacier ceux qui barrent en général
les couloirs où les pentes de nerfs et
barco sais pas si c'est parce que les
italiens ne parlait pas ici ça fallait
faire les pattes qui contrôlent cuite ou
collante la dalle est préparé
n'est ce pas préparé à n'importe qui est
clair
bon ça fait deux heures était en train
de fuir ses pattes et ça donne dubaï
fait requiert pas de trou noir vous
courez pas assez chaude deux heures de
cuisson encore et les pâtes prennent une
consistance qui permet de les ingurgiter
ligne de mentir un des deux partis pour
une nuit
combien d'heures j'ai déjà beaucoup en
montage
encore que
tant attendue celle là
au dehors et pour sortir du glaçon
figurent trois heures du matin départ
pour profiter du froid une course contre
le soleil
il ne faut pas lui laisser le temps de
trop réchauffer la couche de neige
elle deviendrait dangereuse le froid
celles alliées contre les avalanches
derrière eux à une quarantaine de
kilomètres les lumières de la pas encore
grave on se prend pour tous sauf pour
diouf ce qu'en fait on se sent tellement
petit la montagne ces dernières est
immense c'est comme c'est comme si on
s'amusait à regarder les étoiles d'une
nuit très très étoilé un sens
microscopique donc jamais on pourrait se
prendre pour dieu il faut être plus gros
qu'une montagne pour être du plus gros
que la plus grosse des montagnes faut
être plus haut gléon restent les
premiers rayons du soleil sur un sommet
ce serait plutôt aux oiseaux charnois ou
autres les animaux de la montagne papa
l'homme quoi là c'est là justement qu'on
peut se sentir un peu comme un peu au
dessus de tout le monde parce qu'on en a
justement volet c'est à cet instant on
l'a volé un peu la nature quoi
c'est un moment qui nous appartient en
fait pas vraiment juste se lever de
soleil ça ça requinque ça ça redonne de
l'énergie ça ça en fait vivre charles
est vachement jaloux à ce moment là
beaucoup de jeunes finissent des boys
justement pour la voir se lever de
soleil
on dirait que c'est le but de de
certains l'arrivée avant le soleil c'est
une course un peu
ben justement dans les andes ni le
soleil c'était le style or dieu c'était
le dieu soleil pour une seule et c'était
tout donc je pense que ils ont découvert
très rapidement ses sensations de voir
le soleil en premier en
il fait tellement beau et ils m'ont pris
pour un dieu mais trop bien en montagne
on a plus de problèmes en montagne
personnes qui commandent personnes qui
ordonne on va dire que c'est la liberté
pure et simple le plaisir avant tout on
veut aller à droite en bas à droite on
va aller à gauche la gauche ensuite au
pied on suit notre tête
pas besoin de plus quelqu'un vous
conseille d'aller là où là y'a pleins
feux rouges qui va nous dire stop
les personnes qui va nous attendre au
qui me l'a dit ah vous êtes allé trop
vite ça va bien ça commence à monter mal
de crâne quand sa table un peu les temps
comment ça fait bah on commence et j'ai
trop on est à cinq milles 4 marco il
marche assez vite donc je poursuive
reflète un hyper un peu un peu en
hyperventilation c'est pas bon je fais
du manque d'oxygène mais souffre plus
vite et puis pour compenser ces vrais
faux essoufflé faut souffler ça fait mal
au crâne quoi
les derniers 700 mètres ce qu'ils
descendront tout à l'heure les gros
stade de glace à des passages très
étroit visiblement le dieu soleil ne
pleure plus depuis longtemps mais il
fait pleurer la neige et les glaciers
pour marco et philippe il faut avaler
vite ces derniers 700 m 2 fois la tour
eiffel pour ne pas arriver en haut
trop tard la corde en glace et plus moi
je trouve que c'est plus psychologique
efficace une broche à glace c'est pas
comme un gros piton quand même grosse
piqué qui en créant du rocher la grèce
ça reste friable sariska ça ça s'arrache
et j'ai déjà vu partir les gens qui ont
fait toute une cascade de glace sur la
tête parce que toutes les branches
avaient sauté
donc j'ai pas envie que ça m'arrive donc
je fais tout pour pas tomber mon pagne
en vise toujours plus haut et j'avais ya
que quand on est au sommet de l'everest
qu'on se peut se dire y'a pas plus haut
on arrive au sommet reste impression de
liberté et de légèreté aussi d'euphorie
surtout quand on va bien physiquement ça
va les conditions sont bonnes tout va
bien quand tout roule
ça sentiment très très intérieur assez
dur à expliquer très égoïste je pense
c'est là qu'on est chez nous en fait
le sommet mais 700 mètres plus bas les
nuages arrivent ils doivent faire vite
s'ils veulent pouvoir redescendre ce
couloir sur leur surf
enfin
[Musique]
cette ville alors ouais premier de la
poule
je sais pas ça fait pas ouais c'est
psycho quoi mais c'est le brouillard
formelle ça vous fait quelques instants
pour se préparer à la descente
chaussez les surfs et tout vérifier
quelques minutes pour récupérer et
retrouver la lucidité un petit
craquement la fixation de marque casse
pour lui tout s'écroule
les bains chauds ce document pas de
problème une clairière et
il est agité le plus haut jamais péter
philips pour chier quoi bon moi j'ai
monté un équilibre donc décide d'y aller
quand même
avant je suis un premier virage jo pour
le virage qui donne la suite on sera pas
manchots sur terre et me ces tissus
il n'y a pas de consistant je valide et
que ce n'est pas raisonnable
je peux pas le dire si la ville s'en
sort avec moi maintenant il faut dire
c'est comme tu sans convaincre à dubaï à
rien quand même
aux voix ouais
[Musique]
mais j'insiste en ce sens la corde
effectivement il aurait dévalé les 700
mètres du couloir de glace avant
l'arrivée des nuages le dieu soleil
avait trop fait pleurer la neige
elle ne tient plus sur la glace elle
part par plaques entières
c'est vrai c'est vraiment lui mythique
qui se prend la boîte collector fixe il
n'y a pas beaucoup de neige qua non pas
beaucoup de neige sur de la glace
j'en veux plus rien c'est plus un geste
et c'est pas énorme aventure c'est la
sagesse des foies gras et dieu un cas
n'avait pas été sensible à toutes les
incantations des chamans pour la santé
il avait assuré mais pas pour la
réussite complète de l' aventure sans
doute un problème de communication
le mot surf ne fait peut-être pas encore
partie de leur vocabulaire paris retour
sur terre
lagence fdb floris de bonneville son
directeur sur les 468 photo l' agence a
jugé qu' on seulement méritait d'être
proposée aux journaux mais il était trop
tard
a priori pas eu beaucoup de vent oui
mais
vous n'êtes pas non
vous êtes arrivé avec un petit peu de
retard ou est ce petit peu de retard
était suffisant pour que l'on puisse pas
faire de rente en fait ça c'est
typiquement une photo bien cadré et qui
aurait dû lui si elle est sérieuse
attend publié un petit peu partout on
sent qu'il ya certaines étapes à l'eau
certain effroi pas trop déçu mari au
moyen moyen celui-ci déçu parce que
je peux pas attendre mais mes photos
mais la fois c'est enrichissant parce
que j'ai des conseils
c'est une expérience ça m'apprend ça m'a
appris de toutes les façons sur le
terrain à être plus rapide et maintenant
j'en vois j'étais curieuse de voir le
résultat
j'étais curieuse de voir le résultat bon
maintenant je vais essayer de trouver
une petite une solution quand même pour
essayer d'en rendre au moins une
plus encourageant le télégramme de brest
lui a pris quatre articles qui ont été
publiés par le journal
j'ai trouvé le papier mais bon ça manque
un peu de fond je serais allé jours
l'opposition sans manières hubert
coudurier tutoie immédiatement marie la
pratique dans le métier
les élections présidentielles en tout
cas non pas en tout cas nous on
ça fait un bon démarrage une première
signature dans un grand quotidien son
voyage lui a coûté près de 9000 francs
ces articles lui ont rapporté aux
alentours de 5000 au même moment
il est 19 heures dans un lieu pas
franchement déterminé quelque part dans
le sud de la nouvelle-zélande
tian s'inquiète pas du tout
non surtout surtout dans ce pays en
france je crois que je le ferai pas
camping sauvage j'aime bien mais dans
des endroits qui craignent je préfère
être avec des gens mais sinon c'est un
pays
j'ai touche du bois du bois non j'en ai
pas non sarah petit train pas donc là je
pense qu'il aura pas de problème puis là
je suis pas visible de la route
non ça m'inquiète pas du tout j'aime
bien ces bowie pas à voir le coucher de
soleil dans le logiciel
samba et soir où j'ai pas envie de
dormir tout seul j'arrive toujours à
rencontrer des gens qui l'héberge
donc c'est sympa j'ai jamais jamais eu à
leur nos peurs jeunesse donc je choisis
soit je dors tout seul parce que c'est
beau j'ai envie soit soucié des gens et
du coup je rencontre des gens et c'est
sympa ces moments que j'aime bien ça
c'est vraiment deux mondes privilégié du
voyage
j'aime bien temps en temps est tout seul
puis n'avoir à penser qu'à moi pas parce
qu'il faut que je dise pour être poli
pour pouvoir faire ce que je peux penser
bien mon problème sur mon petit vélo je
vois un beau coin je m'arrête s'il
fouette un c'est un peu l'errance le
fait de ne pas savoir où on va puis asie
rebond bas qu'est ce que je veux
maintenant qu'est ce que je veux faire
après puisque ce que j'ai fait jusqu'à
maintenant c'était vraiment ce que je
voulais est ce que je vais dans la bonne
direction
quand je peux rentrer je sais pas ce qui
m'attend je sais pas si je pourrai
longtemps continué à essayer de
transformer mes désirs en réalité mais
mais je sais que je sais qu'on ne fera
plus croire qu'on appelle forte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]